at five las vegas raiders star henry
ruggs arrested accused of a fiery and
deadly dui crash the latest from the
scene and reaction from the raiders
breaking his silence superintendent
jesus jarrah issue in the first
statement since his firing his message
for teachers
76 degrees weather now winds are calm as
well and cooler than yesterday we'll
have more on your forecast straight
ahead
this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
we are following breaking news here off
the top at five a las vegas raiders star
accused of causing a deadly crash on a
local road this video from a neighbor
shows the fiery aftermath early this
morning
this news reaching around the world
today cutting through the sporting world
and the las vegas community and good
evening to you thank you for joining us
on eight news now at five i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez we have
team coverage tonight joe moeller has a
closer look at henry ruggs the young man
accused in that crash chris matthews has
reaction from the raiders but we start
with victoria saha with what we've
learned about this tragic crash victoria
the roads here are back open it took
police more than 12 hours to examine the
scene and take the person who died out
of one of those burning cars
and we are learning that she was a 23
year old person now this early morning
crash shook up this whole neighborhood
metro police confirmed ruggs was driving
his chevrolet corvette when he hit a
toyota rav4 the rav4 was traveling north
on south rainbow by spring valley in the
right lane at the same time police say
ruggs and a female passenger were in his
corvette going fast in the center lane
then veered off to the right lane that's
where the raft 4 was the front of rug's
car hit the rav4 from behind when the
rav4 came to a stop it caught on fire
when first responders got on scene they
found the driver of the raft four dead
she was 23 years old amy rigo lives
right in this area she provided 8 news
now with the video of the rav4 catching
fire i don't know if anybody had time to
take whoever was in there or what or
they were scared because you know corona
whatever but i really felt bad that
you know i feel like
maybe if somebody wasn't just not afraid
could have went out there and helped
them metro police say ruggs stayed on
scene after the crash and showed signs
of impairment he was taken to umc with
non-life-threatening injuries
ruggs was released from the hospital and
taken into the clark county detention
center he is due back in court in court
excuse me tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m
victoria saha live local now
victoria thank you henry ruggs will be
charged with dui resulting in death now
in nevada that charge is a class b
felony it's punishable anywhere from two
to 20 years if ruggs is convicted rugs
could also be suspended by the nfl which
has a personal conduct and a substance
abuse policy rug's attorney david
chesnov and richard schoenfield have
asked the public to reserve judgment
until all the facts are gathered
meanwhile his teammates and victims
families will try to cope with this
tragedy sports director chris matthews
has more now on what the raiders are
saying this afternoon chris joining us
live in studio well thank you very much
brian football is so insignificant
during this time of tragedy it's hard to
imagine what's going on in the minds of
the players right now as they try to
prepare for a game this sunday raiders
headquarters parking lot was full of
cars this afternoon and one can only
imagine the conversations going on
behind the steel bars and inside that
facility shock over the player involved
in a preventable accident that took the
life of another human being it's no
longer about football we caught up with
former nfl quarterback randall
cunningham who is the pastor at remnant
ministries he's also the raiders team
chaplain
uh what's happened it's a tragedy uh but
we just gotta really be encouraging to
both families and yes he's got a little
girl so
um
you know as a pastor and as a chaplain
of the raiders i'm available to you know
just encourage them and encourage both
families
all right both families will need some
help certainly the raiders did release a
statement this morning which reads in
part we are devastated by the loss of
life and our thoughts and prayers go out
to the victims family we are in the
process of gathering information and
will have no further comment at this
time cunningham has had rugs over and
many other raiders over to his ministry
in the past he is also sending his
sincerest condolences to the victims
families denise chris thanks for that so
rugs of course facing some very serious
charges that could result in prison time
and fines and joe mohler continues our
team coverage from the clark county
detention center with more on what now
could be awaiting rugs
after being treated for those
non-life-threatening injuries a few
blocks from here at umc he was brought
to the detention center where he is now
officially charged with duin reckless
driving
in the state of nevada this is a class b
felony and rugs could face anywhere from
two to 20 years in jail metro did not
release specifics about ruggs's injuries
from the crash people have been reacting
to news of the crash since it broke this
morning clark county commissioner
michael naff took the twitter outrage
over what has happened he has been
outspoken about the fatal crashes
happening in the valley lately
i don't care who you are there's no
excuse for this kind of behavior even
more when every single person in our
community has the option to take public
transit if you're drinking if you're
abusing substances every single person
in our community has the opportunity to
call a friend everyone in our community
has the option to take advantage of ride
share services
you know back out here live many fans of
the raiders have been reacting on social
media as well many people expressing
their disappointment with a decision
that was allegedly made last night to
get behind the wheel many people saying
the same thing is naft saying there are
plenty of options out there to take a
safe drive or safe ride to get home
reporting live in downtown las vegas
john muller live local now
henry ruggs is the now 26th nfl player
arrested this year that's according to a
usa today database and of the 26 players
arrested in 2020 six were for dui three
members of the las vegas raiders have
been arrested including running back
josh jacobs for dui in january and
cornerback kima sivaron who was arrested
for evading in texas that was in
february now of course this arrest
coming at a very difficult time for the
team just last month head coach john
gruden caught up in an email scandal
resigned in disgrace an investigation
revealed racist sexist and homophobic
language used in emails to a team
executive a decade ago
another driver is in trouble for driving
right through the middle of the henry
rugs crime scene our camera was rolling
when that driver blew past metro police
vehicles coming dangerously close to the
cars involved officers quickly
surrounded that suv the driver was cited
police want to remind everyone to never
drive through the scene of an active
investigation and we are continuing to
follow the arrest of henry ruggs we're
also working to find out more about the
victims in this crash and you can follow
the latest here on air and online at
8newsnow.com
good afternoon everyone ted florento
here with your weather now another
beautiful day outside the clouds have
cleared air quality also in the good
range temperatures perfect for this fall
november day in the mid 70s at this hour
winds are staying light and calm after
those elevated winds we had yesterday
one shouldn't be an issue for tonight
either in fact here's your evening
planner we'll increase the clouds a
little later on this evening otherwise
mainly clear skies winds less than 10
miles per hour your temperatures for
this evening cooler than yesterday 67 to
9 p.m eight news down 11 at 64. and
we'll be in the high 50s for our morning
start for tomorrow morning so hear your
weather headlines dry and unseasonably
mild winds will be returning but that
will be into the weekend and don't
forget to turn back the clocks this
weekend for daylight saving time we're
going to bring back some clouds too i'll
break this all down for you in your most
accurate forecast in just a few minutes
denise over to you all right ted we'll
see you then so we are hearing now from
clark county school superintendent jesus
jarrah for the first time since he was
fired last week in a statement to ccsd
employees jarrah said he appreciates the
love and support he's received in recent
days he said he has no regrets and that
he always put students first the school
board voted to terminate jarrow's
contract last week he remains the
superintendent until december 1st
now check in the very latest coronavirus
numbers for southern nevada we are
holding steady from yesterday clark
county's test positivity rate remaining
at 5.8 percent new cases increased to
112 per 100 000 residents that pushed
our two-week average back into what is
considered high risk of transmission a
day after it had dropped down into the
substantial category
fans who want to attend unlv basketball
games at thomas and mack will need to
show proof of covet vaccination the
school announcing the policy earlier
this morning it starts next week when
the rebels host gardner-webb fans will
not be required though to wear a mask
once inside the arena
coronavirus vaccine for kids ages 5 to
11 can start immediately the cdc just
gave full emergency approval gosh about
15 minutes ago
studies show children are far less
likely to have serious cases of cobit 19
however 67 thousand american children
under 17 have been hospitalized for
coveted infections that since
august of 2020. nevada expected to get
about 95 000 doses in its first phase
we are closely watching results from two
elections tonight the race for governor
in virginia and new jersey polls closed
about an hour ago in virginia the race
there still too close to call upstar
republican glenn younkin has surged in
the polls in recent weeks but it's not
clear if that momentum is enough to
knock off democrat terry mcauliffe also
too close to call in new jersey where
polls closed at the very top of the hour
we'll continue to update you
and still ahead here at five the future
comes to north las vegas
the self-driving cars bringing good jobs
and billions in new tech to the valley
plus finding good work the questions
potential employees are asking as
companies look to fill jobs here's ted
unseasonably mild for the first week of
november how long can we keep this trend
going details next you're watching eight
news now at five we are